je suis en pleine « descension sociale » !
Néanmoins, si vous acceptiez mon argument,
cela changerait notre façon de gérer notre vie personnelle,
que nous mettrons de côté pour l'instant,
mais aussi notre façon de penser aux problèmes majeurs
de la santé publique et de l'environnement.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer.
Tout collégien aux États-Unis,
y compris ma fille de 12 ans,
apprend qu'il y a trois branches de gouvernement,
les branches législative, exécutive et judiciaire.
James Madison a écrit :
« S'il existe un principe, dans notre Constitution
et bien sûr, dans toute Constitution libre,
plus sacré que tout autre,
c'est celui qui sépare
les pouvoirs législatif, exécutif et judiciaire. »
Les auteurs de la Constitution n'étaient pas uniquement concernés
par la concentration et l'exercice du pouvoir.
ils comprenaient également les dangers de l'influence.
Les juges ne peuvent pas déterminer la constitutionnalité des lois
s'ils participent à l'élaboration de ces lois,
ni demander des comptes aux autres branches du gouvernement
s'ils collaborent
ou nouent des relations étroites avec elles.
La Constitution est, comme l'a dit un célèbre expert,
« une invitation à la confrontation ».
Quant à nous, le peuple, nos intérêts sont servis
quand ces branches se confrontent vraiment.
Nous reconnaissons l'importance de la confrontation
non seulement dans le secteur public,
entre les branches du gouvernement,
mais aussi dans le secteur privé,
dans les relations entre entreprises.
Imaginons que deux compagnies aériennes américaines se réunissent
et se mettent d'accord
de ne pas baisser le prix
de leur classe économique en-dessous de 250 dollars le billet.
Cela s'appelle : « collaboration », certains diraient : « collusion ».
et non « concurrence »,
et nous, les gens, sommes lésés
parce que nous payons plus pour nos billets d'avion.
Imaginez que deux compagnies aériennes disent :
Compagnie A : « Écoute, je prends la ligne Los Angeles-Chicago »
et la compagnie B dit : « Je prends la ligne Chicago-Washington,
pas de concurrence entre nous. »
Ici encore, c'est de la collaboration ou collusion au lieu de la concurrence,
et nous les gens, nous sommes lésés.
Nous comprenons l'importance de la confrontation
s'agissant des relations entre branches du gouvernement,
le secteur public.
Nous comprenons aussi l'importance de la confrontation
dans les relations entre entreprises,
le secteur privé.
Mais là où nous l'avons oubliée,
ce sont dans les relations entre le secteur public et privé.
Les gouvernements du monde entier collaborent avec l'industrie
pour résoudre les problèmes de santé publique et d'environnement,
collaborant souvent avec les entreprises mêmes
qui créent ou exacerbent les problèmes qu'ils essaient de régler.
On nous dit que ce sont des relations
où tout le monde y gagne.
Mais, et si quelqu'un était perdant ?
Laissez-moi vous donner quelques exemples.
Une agence des Nations Unies a décidé de régler un sérieux problème :
le manque d'hygiène des écoles dans les zones rurales de l'Inde.
Ils ont collaboré non seulement avec les gouvernements nationaux et locaux,
mais aussi avec une compagnie de télévision
et une grande multinationale de boissons gazeuses.
En échange de moins d'un million de dollars,
cette entreprise a reçu les bénéfices
d'un mois de campagne de promotion incluant un téléthon de 12 heures,
le tout utilisant le logo de l'entreprise et son jeu de couleurs.
C'était un accord
parfaitement compréhensible
du point de vue de l'entreprise.
Cela améliorait la réputation de l'entreprise
et créait une fidélité à l'égard de la marque, pour ses produits.
Mais, selon moi,
c'est profondément problématique pour une agence intergouvernementale,
une agence qui a pour mission de promouvoir un mode de vie viable.
En augmentant la consommation des boissons sucréées
faites à partir des maigres ressources locales en eau
et bues dans des bouteilles en plastique,
dans un pays déjà en proie à l'obésité,
cela n'est ni durable du point de vue de la santé publique,
ni du point de vue de l'environnement.
Afin de résoudre un problème de santé publique,
l'agence a semé les graines
d'un autre problème.
Ceci est juste un exemple parmi des dizaines que j'ai découverts,
en rédigeant un livre sur les relations entre gouvernement et industrie.
J'aurais aussi pu vous parler des initiatives
dans les parcs de Londres et à travers l'Angleterre,
impliquant la même entreprise promouvant l'exercice
ou bien sûr, le gouvernement britannique créant des engagements volontaires
en partenariat avec l'industrie,
au lieu de réglementer l'industrie.
Ces collaborations ou partenariats sont devenus
le modèle courant dans la santé publique.
Et, de nouveau, ils sont pertinents du point de vue de l'industrie.
Cela leur permet de formuler
les problèmes de santé publique et leur solutions
par les moyens les moins menaçants,
et les plus compatibles avec leurs intérêts commerciaux.
Donc, l'obésité devient un problème de...
prise de décision individuelle,
de comportement personnel,
de responsabilité personnelle et de manque d'activité physique.
Tourné de cette façon, ce n'est pas le problème
d'un système alimentaire international impliquant de grandes entreprises.
Je ne blâme pas l'industrie.
Naturellement, l'industrie s'engage dans des stratégies d'influence
destinées à promouvoir leurs intérêts commerciaux.
Mais, les gouvernements ont la responsabilité
de développer des contre-stratégies
pour nous protéger
et protéger le bien commun.
L'erreur que font les gouvernements
quand ils collaborent de cette façon avec l'industrie,
c'est de confondre
« bien commun »
et « terrain commun ».
Quand vous coopérez avec l'industrie,
forcément, vous retirez de la table
des choses pouvant promouvoir le bien commun
et où l'industrie est en désaccord.
L'industrie ne sera pas d'accord d'augmenter les régulations
à moins qu'elle ne pense que cela permettra d'éviter plus de régulations,
ou peut-être évincer quelques concurrents du marché.
Les entreprises n'acceptent pas de faire des choses
comme augmenter le prix de leurs produits malsains,
car cela violerait les règles de concurrence,
comme nous l'avons établi.
Donc, nos gouvernements ne devraient pas confondre
le bien commun et le terrain commun,
particulièrement quand le terrain commun veut dire :
trouver un accord avec l'industrie.
Je vous donne ici un autre exemple
qui part d'une collaboration de haut profil
à quelque chose qui descend au-dessous du sol,
littéralement et figurativement :
la fracturation hydraulique pour le gaz naturel.
Imaginez que vous achetez une parcelle de terrain,
sans savoir que les droits miniers avaient été vendus.
C'est avant l'essor de la fracturation.
Vous construisez la maison de vos rêves sur cette parcelle
et, peu de temps après,
vous découvrez qu'une compagnie de gaz
est en train de construire un site de forage sur votre terrain.
Telle était la situation difficile de la famille Hallowich.
Très rapidement,
ils ont commencé à se plaindre de maux de tête,
maux de gorge et démangeaisons des yeux,
en plus de la nuisance du bruit, des vibrations
et des lumières brillantes du torcharge du gaz naturel.
Ils faisaient entendre leurs critiques très clairement,
et puis, soudain, il se sont tus.
Grâce à la Pittsburgh Post-Gazette, où cette image est parue
et un autre quotidien, nous avons découvert pourquoi.
Les journaux ont demandé au tribunal : « Qu'est-il arrivé aux Hallowich ? »
Il s'est avéré qu'ils avaient signé un accord, en secret,
avec les exploitants de gaz, un accord « à prendre ou à laisser ».
La compagnie de gaz a dit : « Vous pouvez avoir
une somme d'argent à six chiffres pour aller ailleurs
commencer une nouvelle vie, mais en retour,
vous promettez de ne jamais parler de votre expérience avec notre compagnie,
de votre expérience avec la fracturation hydraulique
et de ne pas parler des conséquences sur la santé
qui auraient pu être révélées après un examen médical. »
Je ne blâme pas les Hallowich d'avoir accepté
cet accord à prendre où à laisser
et d'avoir recommencé leur vie ailleurs.
Et on peut comprendre pourquoi la compagnie souhaiterait
huiler cette roue grinçante.
Ce que je voudrais montrer du doigt, c'est un système de lois et règlementation
un système dans lequel il y a des réseaux d'accords,
tout comme celui-ci.
qui servent à faire taire les gens et sceller l'accès des points de données
aux experts de la santé publique et épidémiologistes,
un système où les organismes de réglementation s’abstiennent
de dresser un procès-verbal de violation dans un cas de pollution,
si le propriétaire et la compagnie de gaz ont accepté un compromis.
C'est un système nuisible du point de vue de la santé publique
et qui expose également aux dangers
les familles locales qui sont restées dans l'ombre.
Bon, je vous ai donné deux exemples, non parce que sont des exemples isolés.
Ce sont des exemples d'un problème systématique.
Je pourrais vous donner quelques exemples contraires,
comme le cas, par exemple, de ce fonctionnaire
qui a poursuivi en justice une compagnie pharmaceutique
pour avoir caché le fait que
son antidépresseur augmentait
les pensées suicidaires chez les adolescents.
Je peux vous parler de ce régulateur qui a poursuivi une compagnie alimentaire
pour avoir exagéré les prétendus effets bénéfiques de son yaourt sur la santé.
Je peux vous parler de ce législateur
qui, malgré un intense lobbying des deux côtés de la Chambre,
insiste sur la protection de l'environnement.
Ce sont des exemples isolés,
mais ce sont des phares dans la nuit
qui peuvent nous montrer la voie.
J'ai commencé par suggérer que, parfois,
nous devons nous engager dans des conflits.
Les gouvernements devraient se disputer,
se bagarrer et parfois, s'engager dans des conflits directs avec les entreprises.
Ce n'est pas parce que nos gouvernements sont foncièrement bons
et les entreprises foncièrement malfaisantes
-- chacun est capable du meilleur comme du pire.
Mais les entreprises agissent selon leurs intérêts commerciaux, naturellement,
et elles le font soit en sapant
soit en favorisant le bien commun.
Alors que c'est la responsabilité des gouvernements
de protéger et promouvoir le bien commun.
Nous devrions insister
pour qu'ils se battent pour ce faire.
C'est parce que les gouvernements
sont les gardiens
de la santé publique.
Les gouvernements sont les gardiens
de l'environnement.
Et ce sont les gouvernements qui sont les gardiens
de ces parts essentielles
de notre bien commun.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)